[Music]
The Lao People's Democratic Republic is
a small landlock country in the Meong
region. It is home to two world heritage
sites. This country is rich in natural
resources such as forest, water, and
agricultural
land. Rice is a staple crop accounting
for 70 to 80% of food grain production.
In the uplands of Laos, farmers grow
rice along mountain slopes, in valleys,
and on terraces. Farmers mostly use
slash and burn to clear land along
mountain slopes and to kill weeds and
soilborn pests before
sewing. These uplands have diverse
agricultural environments that allow
farmers to grow not only rice but also
other crops such as maize, job's tear,
small grain legumes, pepper, sesame,
vegetables and fruits.
Farmers mainly consume these products at
home and sell small quantities for cash
income. They also sell livestock and
forest products such as mushrooms,
bamboo shoots, and medicinal
plants. The major constraints to
agricultural improvements in the area
are low crop yields, weeds, drought,
poor soils, and limited access to
improved technologies and information.
Farmers grow crops in forest edges and
on steep slopes using practices that
contribute to deforestation and soil
erosion. Farmers are caught in a vicious
circle of low yield, high poverty and
environmental degradation.
To overcome these constraints, the
International Fund for Agricultural
Development or IFAD provided funding to
the International Rice Research
Institute to develop improved
technologies for managing rice
landscapes in the uplands for household
food security and environmental
protection.
Increased rice productivity will not
only increase the food supply, but will
also help protect the fragile upland
environment by reducing pressure to
increase food production in steeply
sloping fields. Erie and its partners
are validating technological options
that combine improved plant material
with appropriate resource management
options for increasing productivity.
The project is a collaborative effort
with the Northern Agriculture and
Forestry Research Center or Nafre of the
National Agriculture and Forestry
Research Institute also known as
Nafrey. Most of the research activities
were done in farmers fields in two
villages Bonfi and Bansillech.
Farmers were fully involved in all
stages of this process with the aim of
identifying suitable technologies that
poor farmers can
afford. Farmer participatory research
has identified, selected, and tested
different rice varieties. These improved
varieties have clearly demonstrated
higher yield under both low and moderate
fertilizer application.
In addition to improved varieties,
traditional varieties suited to these
areas have also been identified. The
project has brought back traditional
varieties that are no longer grown
widely because of the unavailability of
seed. Small quantities of seed of these
varieties have been obtained from a gene
bank and evaluated for their
suitability. Additional quantities of
seed have been produced for distribution
to farmers.
[Music]
Scientists have demonstrated that the
use of leguminous plant species such as
pigeon pee accelerate the renewal of
land productivity and give farmers an
opportunity to earn additional income.
For example, farmers culture sticklac
insects on pigeon pee plants and harvest
sticklac resin. Sticklac is used for the
manufacturer of lacquer and this fetches
a high price in the
market. Improved crop management
technologies that are helpful in
achieving better yields were also
introduced in the project. These include
seed selection, testing seed
germination, and weed management.
The project also did research on how to
control weeds. Imperata is a persistent
and hard to control weed in upland rice
fields. Improved methods for controlling
this difficult upland weed have been
validated. Nafra facilitated the
production of more than 24 tons of seeds
by farmers in 2008. This was done with
farmers participation. These seeds were
made available to farmers directly and
through local extension
agencies. Fact sheets in the local
language were published and distributed
and training activities and study tours
were conducted for staff and farmers
involved in the project. The project
also established a partnership with
different local and national
institutions for regional collaboration
and for promoting learning across the
border.
The partnership is strengthened through
extended field validation in Udum Sai
and Saiaburi, neighboring provinces in
Laos in which IFAD has funded large
rural development programs. Improved
validated technologies are being
promoted to farmers who are
participating in these rural development
programs.
Farmers they like uh in upland for
upland area because we have lot of
upland area for highest contribution. So
uh rice uh pigent pee cultivation is uh
very much like by farmer. So they can
get rice and also they can get the pige
and they also improve the soil
productivity. No matter what population
also reduce, insect incidence reduce,
soil erosion also reduce and they reduce
uh they reduce the symptom cycle they
can cultivate on cities of plant for
long time and uh one technology is uh
like zero tillage or minimum tillage
also gaining popularity among farmers.
the following allow government policy.
We try to stop the uh sled and sunburn
there. Okay. So now we try to uh
increase the quality of rice. So if we
cannot do we cannot success this that I
we know that we have never to stop the
the slice and burn.
So the the new technology very important
and will the need for the villages to to
to train them how to to to grow rice and
how to get a high quality.
In four years the project has helped
farmers to identify improved rice
varieties that are suited to their
conditions. The project also helped them
produce good quality seeds and learn new
techniques for improved crop
management. 4 years is a short time and
the challenge remains for these farmers
to continue to increase their yield. The
project may be ending but our commitment
to help the farmers remains. We will
continue to build on the progress made
by the project to develop and provide
better technologies to improve the
well-being of these poor farmers. Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.